[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome
are you brothers companies who's the
youngest yes
how many years 18 years seriously
we're the only two children in the
family where there's a big gap there 18
years when i was 18
my mother told me she was pregnant and i
said don't be so stupid i mean the
thought of one's parents still doing it
yeah
now tonight is not a rehearsal yeah i
want a best performance can we say you
want to yes
yes i know you're not professional chefs
that's clear but what you are
is hungry for success right absolutely
yeah this is not a bushtucker trial yes
this is real meet tonight's family
brigade
the biggins is head of the family
christopher
grew up dreaming of becoming a chef
tonight we'll see if he's made the right
career choice
what's the matter we're burying the
alliance he's drawn by partner neil
a high-flying trolley dolly and a
confident cook
chris's brother sean who works in hr has
recruited wife louise for backup
as a child minder i'm hoping she can
keep biggins in check
and this prima donna will have to cut
back on the theatrics if his family
ought to stand any chance of pleasing 50
hungry diners who expect nothing but the
best
they'll be cooking pea mint and lettuce
soup with parma ham i'm excited
you're excited i'm [ __ ] myself
smoked paprika chicken stroganoff with
spatula you're delusional
i'm not delusional you're on drugs and
vanilla cheesecake with berry compote
well done except biggins
fresh pea soup perfect this time of year
right panda water on
don't put the peas in unless the water
is boiling we'll lose the color that
nice
bright vibrant green color peas minton
peas in now every time we put something
in we had a touch of salt
i'd rather season small amounts as we go
along rather than one big clump at the
end
so look at that very salty flavor nicely
seasoned that's right
yeah but not over salt but i never
salted exactly that as it comes up to
the bowl
lettuce is going to go in then we'll
take them off and drain them
those cooking juices yeah we want just
like you've made a really nice fresh pea
stock
into the blender trend fashion hair just
a touch of stock
and then live on please be careful this
year i don't want it all over the
[ __ ] ceiling more importantly i don't
want it over you
let it gain momentum once it starts to
break down
pour more your stock back in there right
puree puree joy
and the reason why we pure it's so hot
it gets a lot finer if we have to leave
it to cool down a little bit it goes a
little bit lumpy and grainy
we'll go back into the pan we'll bring
it back up to the boil
so we're serving the soup piping hot
soup in
nice thick rich consistency a little bit
of
parmesan little taste
oh no actually dude so simple write any
questions
no are we ready yes yes chef right guys
the biggest brigade yes
table three for super bowl chicken poor
cheesecake
that was a silent there's a [ __ ]
great all right i'll call that out again
i don't know what a full cover table
three yes four soup full chicken four
cheesecake
yeah oh my god that was awesome
i hope we all remember to wash our hands
first rule of the kitchen did you wash
your hands in the jungle when you're
eating kangaroo's penis though
or didn't that matter that didn't matter
all right biggins yes i've been in 15
minutes you've already started talking
about cops
neal i'm excited chef you're excited i'm
[ __ ] myself
so should i put the letters in there
chef as it boils lettuce in is it four
portions of these
[ __ ] it but that is okay guys go please
yes table six
right it's a difficult day for janet
street porter
for the past three and a half months
janet street porter has embarked on the
biggest challenge of her life
hand rearing two veal calves david and
elton in a back garden in north
yorkshire
stop gumming me oh [ __ ]
jenna's aim was not only to rear
delicious meat for the f-word restaurant
but also to persuade the british public
that we should all be eating homegrown
british rose veal
but her campaign has also taken her on
an amazing journey
fantastic you do what do you want
she's nurtured her cars through rain and
shine and with her care and attention
they've grown to five times the original
size
now they're at a good weight for
slaughter it's time for janet to cut the
apron strings
[Music]
today is janet's last day of motherhood
at 20 weeks old
it's time for the calves to leave the
comfort of janet's back garden and meet
their fate
yes come on
janet's been prepared from the beginning
for this day but how will she cope when
she has to say goodbye
you just want to lick everything don't
you
yes yes yes oh god we don't know they're
on death row do they
obviously it's a sad day i
actually don't want to see them being
slaughtered
i would find that very difficult you
know i don't have to prove on that show
i'm not as macho as gordon
[Music]
janet knows that slaughter will be
carried out in strict accordance with ec
and meet hygiene service guidelines
but she's come to the abattoir to see
what that means for herself
hello fellas hi there
elvis and dave david and elton
before david and elton are slaughtered
janet wants to see how the process works
having cared for them for so long she
wants to be sure the death will be as
humane and respectful as possible
licensed slaughterman martin mcintyre
walks janet through the short final
journey the cars will make
and i'm gonna come up this alleyway
and your calves will go up there yeah
but we don't
yeah we follow up here
okay then we shoot them with the humane
killer
stun gun so the shooting's not killing
them
no it's a stone
okay yeah they're actually killed by
slit and that's right yeah
i just don't want to watch you shooting
them or slit in their throat
unfortunately i just don't think i could
right
right
[Music]
will janet be a supportive mother to
david and elton right up to the bitter
[Music]
end
maybe married twice right yes yeah first
time to a lady to a lady yeah and then
neil at their deal yes
that's fascinating how old were you got
married 22
were so young yeah you know in those
early days one thought it was the right
thing to do is to get married you know
and so uh
in mind that you're gay at the time of
the wedding no she didn't know i didn't
know myself
that's enough good nice neil
look at the mess sean oh [ __ ]
unbelievable
you're working [ __ ] you cook like [ __ ]
but the food tastes great chef
[ __ ] hell table seven louise you got
the last two last two
service last table go
[Music]
i think the pee and ham suit work really
really well and you get a real flavor of
the peas up front and then
i think the mint in it kind of comes in
slightly afterwards and
great texture very very soft almost like
a volute it's great
did you enjoy your soup it was gorgeous
how was yours my daddy
not so good oh damn what happened it was
really thick really thick just a bit too
thick as it gets
cold it thickens it was like
it tasted quite nice the flavor was nice
sounds like you've had the one made by
biggins yeah
right results let's find out how you did
the number of customers are paying for
the soup
is
40 out of 51 yes now the ten that didn't
pay
reasons being please bad consistency
what else
lack of mint flavor lack of mint yes
lack of milk something complained about
mint
i want you guys yeah leaving at the end
of here with 50 out of 50 paint in the
main course
and 50 out of 50 pain for the dessert
yes
coming up i meet a zookeeper who
couldn't give a monkey's about healthy
eating
here you are yes not looking after
yourself the grillers are getting baby
gym lettuce we've got michelin-starred
monkeys
and oyster lover rob brydon gets stuck
in
in in twist and twist
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the effort time for the
main course chicken's sogging off
[Music]
normally done with beef but i'm gonna do
with chicken this is a really nice light
healthy approach toggle and so simple to
do chicken breast
slice smoked paprika it gives it a
really nice oat smoky flavour
salt pepper rub across the chicken
[Applause]
hot pan olive oil
the most important part now just lightly
sauteing the chicken
giving a little bit of colour
rest vegetables
onions peppers garlic
mushrooms
the secret here is we're soaking the
vegetables off in the same pan as the
chicken
gently infusing the vegetables white
wine
reduce chicken stock
sour cream chicken sugar snap peas
parsley
[Music]
rest and to finish it off is this little
baby here
especially basically the germans pasta
it's light it's fluffy but more
importantly it's got to be crispy
season
hot pan olive oil
as it hits the pan it puffs up it's nice
and light
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
butter
strong enough
that has to be the perfect strong enough
smoked paprika chicken stroganoff bit
specially
done
look at that chicken it's [ __ ] black
which one that one there
oh dear ah
[Music]
what's the matter we're burning the
aliens no no no no
no no hey would you serve that no don't
wait would you throw that no no
[ __ ] huh come on guys very nice sean
make sure they're all even yes big chef
yeah good there you go
we've got the heat back okay awfully
well
[Music]
right now got the heat back in the pan
okay we start losing the heat we'll boil
the chicken with all the chicken there's
no flavor
right next on the menu a bit of monkey
business
i've come to london zoo to meet hannah
to tell her to stop monkeying around
when it comes to her diet
hannah has worked here as zookeeper and
animal nutritionist for the past four
years
my job here is mostly to look after the
um the primates so all the monkeys and
the apes
good morning yes
each day hannah prepares peanuts and
meal worms for the squirrel monkeys
the chimps get fresh papaya the mama
sets banana
and bobby the silverback griller enjoys
a sumptuous spread of seeds fennel
and curly kale like most of her charges
hannah doesn't eat meat but she's not
looking after herself half as well as
the monkeys and it's beginning to show
i've recently got a gluten and dairy
intolerance
so every day at work i basically have
the same thing it's either gluten-free
pasta with pesto
or a baked potato pasta and baked
potatoes every day
hannah's clearly not getting enough
variety in her restricted diet
and i think her main problem is lack of
protein
hannah good morning how are you i'm very
well thank you it's like a blown up
version of anti-roll thompson
the diet is crucial yes absolutely
vegetable intake vitamin c
you know protein yeah and that balance
is the most important part yeah
absolutely
when was the last time you sat down to a
really good piece of meat
uh a good good three three and a half
years ago
any reason i think having started at the
zoo
you kind of start to get a different
outlook on on the
on how animals are treated the sort of
meat that you eat
i've always been i was always careful
about what meat i ate before
so you would eat meat if it was you know
yeah probably uh red
organic absolutely bobby the silverback
griller is a great example
of what a healthy balanced diet can do
for you
bobby there we go he's having his he's
having his fruit tea now
fruit tea i'm surprised he's not my earl
grey
it's lunch time for bobby and the other
animals so hannah and i are off to make
it
right this is our cutting up room it's
like a prep room for a restaurant
you've got the frizzy lettuce cabbage
cardamom lemon peel allspice
this is a joke isn't it avocados we're
serving avocados as well no it's good
for them it's very you know obviously
it's
essential fatty acid and would you like
it turned into
we do make guacamole yeah you make
guacamole film as well and avocado
prawns avocado crab or
spinach chicory fricassee iceberg fennel
spinach broccoli we've got
michelin-starred monkeys
i'm i'm stuck here you are yes not
looking after yourself
man the grillers are getting baby gym
lettuce absolutely you're smart
man are you um baby gem lettuce no one
is a [ __ ] shortage for the
restaurants
i'm going to cook hannah a deliciously
healthy dish using the same ingredients
she feeds bobby the gourmet griller with
no dairy or gluten
just to show you that all the stuff
you're working with down there yeah it
can be equally
exciting for you first up coleslaw
don't lose any nutrients through cooking
raw is more celeriac carrots and cabbage
are all packed with vitamins and fiber
and give the dish a delicious crunch
i love the smoky bitterness of chicory
and it's very low in cholesterol
i'm gonna make a quick vinaigrette so
two thirds olive oil
one third sesame seed oil yeah a little
bit of mustard
okay poppy seeds just a tablespoon makes
a great contribution to your daily
calcium needs
lemon juice and parsley help the
digestion of proteins and fats
they also taste great and then uh
vinegar within three or four minutes the
seasoning is going to start breaking
down
the coleslaw
and now for my wild card hannah's fed up
with her unbalanced boring gluten-free
diet
she may not have eaten meat for three
years but now she thinks she's ready to
give it another go
so i'm phoning at the deep end with a
delicious protein-rich steak
um this is the kind of beef it's reared
um in airshow
yeah it's fed on grass in the summer uh
swedes and turnip in the winter
so it's a proper organic beef when i did
eat meat i would try and eat
organic i don't like the way the animals
are mass produced
no i stand strong on that one nor do i
how do you like your beef how do you
like it cooked
medium yeah yeah fine so we'll cook it
remember okay for the dressing shallot
i believe that good quality lean meat is
a key part of a healthy diet
so i'm hoping this dish will help hannah
back on the road to recovery
turn over the steaks a delicious
tarragon dressing should make her first
fill it's taking years
a little easier to deal with so it's
quite a spicy marinade
target we just cut once
slightly faster give it a stir and add
to the steaks
delicious what we're going to do is
spoon that over so as the beef
starts to cool down it absorbs all that
amazing
flavor finally
finish the coastal with coriander and
it's ready to go
[Music]
i can't believe you can put so much
different flavors and taste just into
coleslaw i haven't quite i managed to uh
take on the beef you put the most
amazing energy into looking after these
animals so
you need protein yeah absolutely a good
bit of salmon do you think
something someone worked perfectly just
not quite ready for the uh for the red
meat
don't you worry about that i'll use it
all right what's the matter we have
quite some complaints over the uh
saltiness in the dishes
complaints about what sauce do my sauce
hey guys the dining room were
complaining about the seasoning
i haven't done any seasoning but we
aren't putting any i haven't touched
a little bit you haven't cut the salt no
when you see the spatula how are you
seizing that
small amounts no nothing at all nothing
at all
i i promise you nothing okay okay let's
go
how about thank you sean make sure it's
spotless yeah
sure yes
[Music]
biggins you're eating and the [ __ ]
customers aren't i thought we were
finished now we're not [ __ ] finished
come on guys we can do this yeah let's
go let's do it chef
yeah last table yeah we've got the creme
fraiche or the come on come on cream
there baby chicken back in
biggest big settings six there babe well
done
serious guys [ __ ] for sure and the wings
sean thank you for the [ __ ] good
effort biggins
you were [ __ ] halfway through i told you
about the season customers complained
about me salty
i saw you clump soul i swear on my
life i never touched swords at that time
never ever touch up
if god strike me down dead who sees this
vegetal then
i have no idea touched seriously so i
put salt in i would have told you i am
not a liar
you're delusional i'm not delusional
you're on drugs why are the customers
complaining salty though and i don't
know because it must have been from
summer but it was
i put no [ __ ] swords at all in any of
that
[Applause]
[Music]
rob hey how are you doing good to see
you guys welcome welcome welcome join
the food
yeah i love you and you enjoy wine yeah
yeah you didn't start actually drinking
until
you're in your 30s right no i i grew up
and i never i never drank and it's an
odd thing know
that means you must have been stone
sober virginity
that i didn't think we're gonna get on
to this um
yes yes i was yes i was any regrets yes
no
good god she's probably watching what
was it like i hope she was one of the
best teachers at that school and i'll
tell you what
that tribunal came down on her too hard
you're at the same school as kathleen
caesar jones i was yes
was she trying to get off the teachers
back then uh looking for that older
figure out she
used to come in with the streets of san
francisco on vhs look at this this guy's
really hot
this man is fantastic dimple he's got
their favorite foods to eat what do you
enjoy most
i adore oysters how important is it with
an oyster that it has
the the juice still in it it's crucial
and i never eat an oyster unless it's
stuck to the shell when they're released
and they're put back in it could be from
a different shell so you need it
seriously you think someone would do
that well sometimes they do they clean
the shelves they put it in the
dishwasher and then they get the oysters
from other shelves and stick them in
there
no criminal mastermind would do
something like that
hold that thought i've got a very
special treat for you all right come
with me oh okay yeah
you're a big fan of oysters yeah look
what i've got for you
okay he was acquitted on all charges
remember and then he should be allowed
to perform again
i hear yeah you're a [ __ ] good
shocker i'm a hell of a shocker
show me one you go in that end
oh is the [ __ ] the menu in there
yeah that's where it's prized that's the
thin end so as you go in
it's brittle it breaks the shell and you
get all these bits i did 12 like that
last weekend at the wrong end set at the
wrong end
now the secret is yeah release the
muscle
in twist and pop off i've got it i've
got it that's it good
leave let's half the skirt on the top of
the show i know
i'm not a chef go and do some comedy
cheeky bugger
right there we are done okay okay good
little tip plate
tin foil oh okay and you get them there
and just sit them in the tin foil
and it keeps the oyster up it doesn't
lose its juice you know what i'd
normally do though
is i put some crushed ice on the plate
is that is that the time you've opened
[ __ ] three well at my speed yeah
yeah we're gonna have a shock off yeah
okay we've heard you can guess the
winner of this
how many are we trying to get through
we're gonna get through the whole train
together
ready steady steady go go go
twist low down away in in twist and
twist
up keeping all the juice in
where's that gone in i mean twist i'm
not popping
come on
[Applause]
come on come on come on it's really
close
in twist and
in huh we've got an obviously
i'm in i've done it i'm in good manner
good man good man come on
in i've done the second one on
you should be to twist the knife once
the points in and release the muscle
i've released my
on a muscles [ __ ] you know he's in it
again uncle braden
uncle bryn is coming back five oysters
let's go oh look who's winning let's go
see how easy it is to release the muscle
oh my god look at that
[Applause]
come on
[Applause]
yeah sorry hold on you pinched one from
mine
didn't you yeah
that was very good thank you you're a
[ __ ] good shocker you know
[Applause]
was very salty and it overpowered any
other flavors that were there
how was the main course really salty
really salty
i'm so sorry um chicken or the veg um no
the veg
are you playing yes i am playing and
five of you aren't right
you are personal that's very generous it
was still very very well i'm so sorry it
was salty thank you these are patients
thank you very much the stroganoff was
very good chicken was really soft
um you could really taste the smokiness
of the paprika and the sauce was very
rich
it was a really lovely dish right
results may cause
okay the amount of guests that paid yeah
out of 50
is oh jesus
jesus i can't even call that out 17.
that is the worst we've ever had no
really guys i'm here for perfection
and that is shocking what do they say
well
the majority over salty so salty yeah
can we come back for dessert yes coming
up
after eight weeks in the making i
finally get to neck a bottle of my home
brew
it's extraordinary next one my very own
beer
and it's time for janet to say goodbye
to david and elton
[Music]
[Applause]
right it's recipe challenge time jessica
hines is taking me on with her macaroni
and cheese
yes first of all good to see you tell me
about macaroni and cheese
macaroni cheese start with macaroni yes
it's a form of pasta yeah because you
didn't know that
it's like a pasta okay now why have you
chosen cheese
because it's delicious it's easy to cook
my kids love it
i feel quite confident cooking it now
you know the blind tasters aren't
children today don't you this is
actually slightly more adult version
and what makes it an adult version well
it's put onion in it
onion grated onions so if you don't like
that you might not like it yes so just
making macaroni and cheese of course i'm
gonna do macaroni and cheese this one's
gonna be done with um wonderful
juror mushrooms so a bit of a wild
mushroom thing going on are you gonna do
any work today or are you gonna
listen this is just you know i'm
chilling here i'm just
looking we're just watching you that
you have lots of children so normally
i'd be going no stop it what
uh come here come here that's why it's a
good recipe you're just boiling the
macaroni cheese there
you grew up in a bit of a sort of hippie
household what kind of things did you
eat
lots of lentils and yogurt right lentils
and yogurt my mum used to make
bread well you're not vegetarian are you
i was a vegetarian after my son was born
i just
went off eating meat actually oh really
welcome back
and uh no i got pregnant with my with my
daughter yeah and i didn't even know i
was pregnant i was two weeks pregnant
and i was at barbecue and there was a
big plate of spare ribs
and i would have eaten the person yeah
standing in front of the spare ribs if
that's what it took to get to them i
didn't know i was pregnant at the time
amazing
and then when i saw the spare ribs yeah
my intense desire for serums made me
think i'm pregnant i must be pregnant
oh sure they're amazing yeah macaroni is
hard cooked and then i'm just going to
glaze the pan touch the white wine
and start making a really nice white
wine cream sauce
my white sauce is is basically like
anybody else's white sauce which is just
melt the butter
put the flour in stir it up and then i
add
for this not too much but just a couple
of pinches of jerk seasoning
which is kind of caribbean seasoning no
flour in my white sauce just cream
shallots and thyme and girals
wow bring it up to the boil and then i'm
going to thicken it
with this amazing cheese i'm using
stitching cheese which is quite
sort of rich and very um slightly salty
but absolutely delicious perfect for
macaroni and cheese
so how did you start off in comedy how
did you get into it well i
am i i was always being picked for comic
rolls
we had a couple of teachers they used to
write us these little sort of um
plays so i just kind of thought maybe i
didn't do this there's a lot less female
comedians than there are male comedians
why is that i think it's more important
for them to think they're funny so yeah
which is weird no
yeah i think it's because men just think
they're funny jess you know that that's
true too
you know in terms of that level of
arrogance maybe women aren't as funny as
men
i don't think that i know i'm wondering
maybe that's why no
okay so cream has reduced down now to
this really nice
mushroom creamy sauce season it with
chives
and then egg yolks in that will help it
sort of
glaze in the oven as it bakes parmesan
cheese
then we're going to add the macaroni
back
in to the cream bake and then win
i've just made a white sauce nice and
slowly and now i'm um
grating red onion so the onion is going
raw you can sweat the onion off very
quickly if you wish to sweat it
oh you're gonna put it sweat when it
cooks and that's the point the point is
you want a little bit of the onion
right you don't want onion oh onion and
then finally
where's the in a macaroni now grated
cheese on the top
that's it finito i'm gonna win
right so they're both in the oven now
tomorrow where do i put it at the top
i would like it to go there okay no
actually where are you gonna put yours
oh i'm just asking he's coming out you
ladies first
you go first where are you putting yours
hey i want to put mine in there too can
i both go there
of course i can okay of course
good luck you are so competitive you
know that huh right
it's time to bottle my special f-word
beer
two months ago i set off on a mission to
find and brew a beer that would
complement janice reporter's veal
it's a very mellow creamy rich beer that
is delicious
that i could then brew my own back
garden super sweet
great that is incredible you know we've
got some nice hooks we'll get a lovely
smooth creamy flavor to the beer that's
like a witch's potion when you
stir it a witch's potion excuse me hey
this is your dad's very own beer
i thought this [ __ ] works [ __ ] it
nine days later the brew was ready to be
transferred into an oak bourbon barrel
where it spent several weeks absorbing
the barrel's unique caramel flavor
the barrel this is where all the flavor
comes from so we're going to put the
beer in here for 30 days
and it's going to transform it add a lot
of oak character a little bit of vanilla
we just need to
pump it into the barrel now yeah so i've
brought these staves
just to show you this is a part of an
oak barrel right right it's been used
for bourbon
yeah before they fill it with bourbon
they char it they fire the inside
incredible and that's why you've got
this black coloration it's charcoal
surely would make the bear darker though
no no it doesn't make the beer darker it
actually takes a bit of color
and you can see this layer here it's
where the bourbon has previously soaked
into and it's changed the flavor of the
wood in there
so that now when our beer's going in
here yeah that flavor that's in there
comes leaching out and goes into the
beer and that's where we get the sort of
vanilla the creamy character
of this beer ah to get it all
canny scottish trick there come on
get it only scotland get that one
right down to the last four
the smell is amazing it's sort of
biscuity creamy flavor unbelievable i
mean it's just getting better and better
and better this is going to really
change things
really transform it there we go two
months later
the beer is ready to be bottled and
drunk
a house protana has had to put up with a
lot over the years and has drawn the
line of me building a beer bottling
plant in the garage
so dougal and i wait out a view of my
house to meet a man with a mobile
bottling solution
so this guy yes got a bottling line on
the back of this lorry
so this thing's mobile travels around
the country bottling beer yeah
unbelievable oh my god
i can spot the barrel bloody hell
this mobile bottling unit will cool and
filter the beer removing any remaining
yeast
and then carbonating it to give it a
light fizz my first ever bottle
homemade brew it needs to be perfect
it's too late to start over
oh it's [ __ ] delicious brewing my
beer in the whiskey soaked oak barrel
has really paid off
extraordinary next one my very own beard
the flavor will work brilliantly with
janet's veal so the exciting thing now
will be coming up with a veal dish that
can
match that you got something to be said
yeah absolutely absolutely
oh jesus look like that's definitely
[Music]
i feel like i'm [ __ ] willy wonka
charlie the chocolate factory
i think we've got a unique homemade
bottled beer there don't you yeah i'm
looking forward to something i'm very
happy with i can't wait to see the
feedback in the dining room
beautiful what a process and can't wait
to taste it
alongside the veal now one more job the
labels i think i'll get the kids
involved with that
here it is look at that
that is our very own yes home brew
homemade beer what does it say jack
a traditional agent in a whiskey barrel
for a smoother finish brewed in the
ramsey family garden london 2008 how
cool
yes how cool is that try and keep them
all nice and straight okay
that's very good nice daddy's this one
okay
that's personal touch turn it around
oh yeah yeah that is terrible uh you got
air bubbles in there as well dear idea
well at least in an individual aren't
they
teddy it doesn't really matter look at
that beautiful
put your tongue out put your tongue
[Music]
off out of rehab by 12.
[Music]
the kids approve but what will the
diners think when i serve my beer with
janet's veal
i'll find out in two weeks time
make sure your cream cheese is soft
before you start adding your cream
otherwise it'll be a nightmare to mix
sugar in and another pan on there sean i
started the caramel yes
right time for dessert vanilla
cheesecake with berry compote
[Music]
a really nice exciting quick cheesecake
served with a strawberry and blueberry
compote
biscuits blitz
hot pan sugar we're gonna form a really
nice light
golden caramel butter
as the butter dissolves put in your
biscuits
[Music]
coat the biscuits in the caramel they
become really nice and crunchy
cool very compact
hot pan sugar
strawberries blueberries
and look what's happening now you've got
that really nice caramel texture
delays the pan with this little baby i
creme the cassis
giving it a really nice dark texture
cool cheesecake cream cheese in
vanilla icing sugar to sweeten up the
cream cheese
mix lemon
cream whisk
i'm gonna fold the cream into the cream
cheese
fill biscuit crumbs
to release the cutter heat round the
outside of the ring
blow torch very gently
compost
[Music]
touch of mint that has to be the perfect
quick delicious vanilla cheesecake
then in a cheesecake with berry compote
done okay careful those plates don't get
too hot
begins yes sir for me let's take this
really serious yeah
yes you end on a high yeah and we don't
look [ __ ] stupid yes okay sir thank
you
well done shortly change space with
mediocre down the other end
good with the topping make sure those
rings are full yes
yes otherwise you take off the cutters
they look [ __ ] kneel
fill your ring up begins yes sir
you can see why i take this seriously
this is my career yes i don't know i'm
sorry are you very serious
yes because i've got the i've got the
weapon here just be careful
yeah you be careful and concentrate i
keep concentrating if you're already
well concentrate harder right berries on
okay guys nice and smart yes simple
dessert simple presentation we can't pop
this up on
this chef begins mint and sand yeah
absolutely spotless
and san jose you know we've got to clean
the plate first
well we can do this let's get all 50.
how long are you doing that since 2006.
how long have you been together as a
couple how long
14 years and in 14 years what has he
taken serious
nothing he just can't take anything
seriously unreal
sean lovely absolutely spot on
help over here mint and wipe the plates
please
chris good to see you're busy [ __ ]
too many cooks for the brother that's
right yes
meanwhile chris is busting his ass
unfucking real go
well done except biggians huh well done
gang
right back to dennis street porter and
trust me this one is not for the
squeamish
david and elton janet's two veal calves
are about to be slaughtered
but jan is not sure she can bear to see
them killed i just don't want to watch
you shooting them
all slit in their throat unfortunately i
just don't think i could
you ever have farmers who can't face
watching it at all
no david's time's up first
and as he's led into the stunning box
janet has a change of heart
and decides she wants to stay with him
to the end
she's been to abattoirs before but never
to see the slaughter of animals she's
reared personally
the slaughter of cattle in the uk is
governed by strict guidelines and can
only be carried out by licensed
slaughtermen
like martin mcintyre he'll ensure the
animals have caused minimal stress
and make the kill as quick as possible
okay
yeah fine
[Music]
the captive bolt renders david heavily
stunned from this point
he won't feel anything
the blood's drained from the body before
they process the carcass
you okay the stunning was fine the blood
split and i could do without
if it starts to twitch it's just nerves
now it's time for janet's second calf
[Music]
elton
[Music]
now the cards are gutted the parts of
the cards that can be eaten are
separated from those that can't
do you want them what bollocks
testicles no it's okay it's only got one
napkin
oh which one only have one [ __ ] elton
david
so you'd only have one ball yeah
oh that's disgusting the lungs
are windpipe very healthy obviously it
wasn't a smoker
janet's time as a farmer is over and
it's time for the veal to be prepared
the cars will be hung for up to 10 days
to improve the flavour before dave is
enjoyed by janet's friends in north
yorkshire
and elton's delivered to the f word
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
restaurant
fine thank you you're looking very
countrified
do you knit that no i [ __ ] didn't
miss it at all
okay it's a designer item
jesus christ now alton and david are
officially they're dead
go on best slaughtered and i saw before
i
went to the slaughterhouse i didn't
think that i could even
go in the building i hope to change your
mind i was persuaded by the
slaughterhouse itself
because it's a very small uh family
business it's in the middle of the
yorkshire dales
and quite honestly if animals are going
to be sorted that's the way to do it
personal it was personal and it seemed
to be part of the environment
do you have any second thoughts about
not sending them and actually pulling
one back and saying
hold on get out no because gordon they
were never pets they were always
reared to make a point about field
though the carcasses look magnificent
yes they look really good
the animal inspector said they were top
quality
me it's made me want all of me the ie
to have had a decent life and i just
don't know how anyone watching this
program can quite frankly
go and buy cheap nasty meat you just you
think
you know you owe it to yourself and you
owe it to animals
to make sure that you know where that
meat came from and how it was
one last thing just yeah a little
present from me something to sort of
remember them by enough
just for you for your kitchen wall above
the argo oh that's lovely isn't that
nice
yeah good luck is the dribble
that's what i will remember
[Applause]
coming up i find out if i'm still the
big cheese in the macaroni recipe
challenge
well they did like both okay come on
[Applause]
right time for the blind tasers to taste
both macaroni and cheeses okay nice
generous portion nice generous portion
okay bear in mind they are quite fussy
are you happy with yours by the way yeah
i'm very very happy with it
there we go rice i like this bit that's
where it gets really exciting
which one would you choose which one
just visually macaroni cheese there
that's macaroni cheese that
i don't know what that is right jose
come back with the right result yes if
you want a job next week
good luck yes good luck you're gonna
need it
hello so here we have our first
and the second dish lovely enjoy
quite salty the the cheese is quite
strong
it's got quite a strong flavor that
comes through i quite like the the fact
that the pasta's not not too overdone
this is still quite quite firm really
enjoying that
it looks great this one yeah i really
like the mushrooms in there and it adds
quite a strong flavor and the cheese is
different i think it's a good gonzola
oh something blue okay right here we go
right jose
come in was it the raw onion or was it
the wild mushroom
well they did like both they like both
oh dear don't like me tell me that okay
come on
gordon one yes
i honestly thought you were gonna win
the joke season in the white sauce the
ketchup garnish
yours was delicious come on the kids are
gonna love it it's fine
and i think it's ten times better than
dealios thanks a lot thank you
pleasure having you in the kitchen yes
it's been a pleasure being here thank
you thank you
chicken stock cooking the macaroni yes
yes
cheesecake is fabulous it was a really
good combination of sort of crunchy
biscuit base
the actual cheesecake bit was really
nice and light and creamy with subtles
or vanilla through it
and the fact that this fruit was still
quite warm it really made it
superb oh dear what happened the fruit
combat was gorgeous
yes the um the actual cheesecake it was
almost like a
poorly flavored panna cotta it wasn't
that cheese taste to it
poorly flavored panna cotta
taste it gone
you must be with me on it yeah it needs
more icing sugar in there yeah yes
you're definitely not paying for it
right jose let's go results please now
let's see how you did the number of
customers going to pay for dessert
out of 32.50 18. didn't pay tell me
no own up tell me didn't you like
there's a lot of them out there
why josie white not sweet enough not
sweetener not sweet enough
that was the main not sweet enough
should yeah sweet
did you keep on tasting it yeah before
it went in the cutter yeah it's
delicious
that's a grand total of 89 out of 150
that is [ __ ] yeah neil yeah it will be
coming by
billions wow don't say anything just
[ __ ] off my kitty get out
all the way out out out
no don't clap they were terrible
oh my god